I think it would start with knowing
yourself and trusting in yourself that
your instincts as women are usually
right on and that they should be trusted
be different be yourself which sounds
like such a cliche but but be eccentric
and weird and wear funny things and
don't try to be the same as everyone
else it's a bit kinder to themselves my
advice to young women is threefold
one long country walks get a bit of air
in your lungs it keeps you sane to
masturbation it takes the edge off three
the revolution always pursue it I think
the most important advice that I've ever
gotten is to really be myself I can't
really excel being anybody else but if I
can be myself at least I'm being honest
my advice to young women is to be
confident in your own opinions but also
remain open to new ways of thinking
about things
I think young women these days have
quite a tough experience because they
have so much imagery of other people's
lives and experiences on social media
and the internet and I think you then
start to compare yourself to other
people and it can be quite a dangerous
sort of vicious circle to get into so I
think the main bit of advice is just to
sort of leave who own experience in your
own life not worry about what everyone
else is doing and feel really good and
confident about that which is easier
said than done my advice to young women
would be not to be afraid to be
ambitious my advice to young women is do
not wait for permission I think
a lot of times girls are raised to be
permission-based
ask for guidance to ask for advice to
ask for a warrant to do what they want
to do and I think that's an
extraordinary to speak up and don't be
afraid to let your voice be heard worry
less yeah just breathe in our control
pumped yeah
read books study hard choose wisely be
nice to everyone
yeah be lovely to everyone work hard and
enjoy it do it cuz like that look at me
I need two new Hicks that's falling
apart I was born five seconds ago and
it's almost over so relish it that's
really good advice have lots of sex and
cake
you